اخي الكريم انا نايم الساعه اربعه اربعه
وثلث بالضبط والله ما بعرف كان في عيلتي
عم بتصلي تهجد
مباشره من اول ما حركه البنايه صاحت علي
ابو عبده ابو عبدو انا مباشره جلست
رده هزه هزه اقوى من اول مره قلت لها هزه
ارضيه هاي قلت لها هزي ارضيه والله المره
الثالثه صارت الهزه اقوى يعني صرنا نصيح
كلياتنا الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر في
عندي
مرت ابني كمتي فتحت علينا باب الغرفه يا
عمي يا عمي قلت له خولي يا الله
وكلياتنا صرنا نصيح بصوت واحد يا الله يا
الله والله العيله
الاولاد ونطلع والله حملنا حالنا وتوجهنا
على باب الغرفه واذا ما حسينا الا فقصه
البنايه فينا وانا صرت تحت الركام وما عدت
اعرف ايش هو اللي حصل ما بعرف
المهم بعدين من اهل الحاره من الحي
اجوا طالعوني من تحت الركام
وتوفى عندي
بنت وصافي ولدين
[موسيقى]
عمره تسع سنوات في هذا الطفل اللي عم بحكي
عنه قبل فتره عم بصلي اجت امي طبعا ام
عيلتي ام زوجتي متوفيه قال اجيت علي امي
وصارت تشاددني هيك مشادده بدها شيء مني
والله
بيركين والاولاد بيركين كلياتهم عم بسمعوا
عندي هذا الطفل اللي راح بالزلزال بعد ما
انتهت امه من الخص والا بخلي يا بابا انا
اذا متت حطني جنب ستي